[Musique]
le téléthon 2016 aura lieu les 2 et 3
décembre prochains la présentation de
l'événement s'est faite à l'espace
régler en présence de malades du parrain
et de la marraine de cette édition 2016
hendaye avec la musique le sont avec la
famille entre amis famille gagne 1
partout entre sommes donc ravis de vous
entourer un nom de la musique à nos
chantiers
navals à dire j'en avais oui touchés par
des par des personnes que j'ai
rencontrées et puis
n'importe qui et moment donné peut être
touché moi ma cause en tout cas ce que
ce qui prend les tripes c'est les
enfants l'enfance
et l'idée de donner le maximum de
chances à chacun de réaliser son
potentiel maximum voilà c'est ça à la
base qui touche à moins donc forcément
cette cause n'était pas le défi de cette
30e édition reste le même que les années
précédentes
récolter des dons afin de faire avancer
la recherche dans la connaissance et la
mise au point de traitements pour les
maladies génétiques rares
le téléthon c'est c'est c'est une grande
avancée parce que déjà
personnellement il m'a fallu très
longtemps pour connaître de quelle
maladie j'étais atteinte au départ la
pose du diagnostic s'est fait
au bout de nombreuses années parce que
justement là les recherches n'étaient
pas suffisantes on n'avait pas assez
d'avancé pour connaître quel était le
gène touchés quelle est exactement la
maladie dont j'étais atteinte et tout ça
c'est grâce donc dons du téléthon qui
ont permis ces recherches et qui
permettent aujourd'hui que mes enfants
soient dépistés que mes petits enfants
le seront et donc ça apporte un bien
être un confort de vie aussi le
département de la réunion est un
partenaire actif de cette manifestation
cette année la commune de saint-joseph
est désignée comme ville ambassadrice du
téléthon plus d'une quinzaine
d'associations seront mobilisés pour des
animations de terrain sur l'ensemble de
la commune et à ce titre on organisera
un village téléthon du lundi jusqu'au
samedi
dans tous les quartiers s'appuyant sur
les dynamiques associatives qui sont les
relais donc vers leurs adhérents et vers
la population réunionnaise et toutes ses
forces vives tout cet engagement cet
investissement se retrouvera sous la
halle françois mitterrand le samedi lors
de la remise des dons les 2 et 3
décembre prochains l'association afm
téléthon compte sur la générosité des
réunionnais se mobiliser pour faire un
don afin de soutenir les malades et leur
famille va voir précisé qu' il y a deux
moyens principaux de collecter des dons
c'est les animations d'abord de terrain
mais c'est aussi le 36 37 avec la ligne
unique du don qui fonctionne pendant 30
heures au moment du téléthon et cette
ligne il y à un centre d'appel à la
réunion tenue par des bénévoles des
lions
l'année dernière nous avons collecté
450000 euros cette année nous espérons
aller pourquoi pas doubler la mise si je
puis dire il ya plus de huit cent mille
habitants la réunion
si chaque réunion c'est un symbole
chaque réunionnais donner un eurobond
voilà huit cent mille euros
[Applaudissements]
le 2 3 décembre fait manière donne donne
[Musique]